reading for the assortment for the
second time right to the to the wrap-up
of our thrilling code-breaking session
and so we have a we have a great TV show
for you now and the main thing is for us
to so that each of you will be able to
see not only yourself but also also the
other thrilling team competitions in
there so let's go with the first with
the first one I'm afraid that we can't I
can't say anything during the discussion
so listen carefully they will have a
short discussion after each one thing
will have a rapid discussion of the
whole of the whole series and I also
want to ask questions like what changes
to the code encoding scheme would have
would have defeated all of us okay
Rollem I think we're going to be able to
hear the bit make they claim we're going
to be able to hear the audio
first of all we go through and we have
five words middle fill it appears there
are certain sins laughs
I'm sorry
okay is this look moms yes I think we
decided frustrations 250 I change yeah
and finest probation so you sit Matt
look first please he achieved context
don't very common is you'll have to
explain to me out or outright okay I
haven't seen them how ask you so much
yeah can you believe any people's not
into slices this one is a bit of a
finish one you have to cover letters
there's a folder yeah this is yeah but
that's for the seven yes or no sure
maybe some numbers who good how do we
stop them from trying to spell
Oh Ricky come on move it
um this is /
for another lesson okay okay I think we
should L do that traitor it's probably
isn't really there yeah it's been 24 now
if you recall it the coordinates
specific how to season ever they are
from here are you doing I'm just
thinking thinking I can accept you
students for one hei their music we
could try a space Hindi 25 okay and when
you bunches after one deep 29 good fun
that would be really wouldn't any news
from wanting this is pressing the right
Frances progress by staff as well um
that's do
how about research for a note for
closing for work I'm opening line
beginning I'll see where we have some
this local quite there but we have
collagen clear you have another one here
there are sooo many including before not
eloping so maybe it's maybe it's custard
people talking I haven't even said
that's good second red see things like
then I can get a 1 there yeah also sarah
yet this is not said this place is not
for a possible okay ah i just saw
something better honestly I want to keep
doing I think this is going to take too
long to succeed besides Bobby's down
it says two parts to the huge sink
laughing with you know that's a
convention in all and creates a
convention for double quote so maybe
there should be a another fun baby some
a rub up and I don't know anything
actually if I had to realize it for
because we did actually get those two
codemaster together before then i
deleted something but really it's
probably something wrong here or it
might be two times during 22 new to
Paris another room 32like theater chosen
can be settled company where that's at
yeah yeah yeahs there which is why it's
good what's morning here this pair is
also very talking Rizzoli talking
passenger see it could be that there's
two black lines because somebody else
started talking after levels of the
office but then what other duck years
that have come there but yeah maybe we
should try and go stop them I don't know
where we can also try again I'm trying
to add Susan oh yeah i thought i'd try
nails at the beginning it didn't work
i'm not sure what happened there
quitting at once it doesn't doesn't this
is a different life charlie princess no
single n things it's very useful towards
the end when you've got words you need
to see how they relate to this this is
citrus and like this important ladies
it's only sing so if there isn't that
where the calming down they probably had
exclamation life or something like that
after that that's in 21 well it was just
before okay now i feel like the
c-terminal yeah it's pretty good time
for that's too bad that that word was
what stayed through the whole thing and
and with an inhibiting factor in the
solution but it was but there was there
was some progress as you could see and
although it didn't make it in 45 minutes
it wouldn't have been too long before
before they were too converged I think
well actually we changed our improved us
and something in our program and we
added a comment since then which would
have probably had this a lot this
command is some call it look up and it
searches all the possible letters in a
certain position in the message so given
the the present status of the decoding
it gives all the remaining passive
everything that could go in there yes we
did that now yes oh good because the
audios you see in some of the other
solutions that's a very very helpful law
yeah okay okay so let's go up with the
second second
by the way and if I make any remarks
there anything they don't mean anything
honey don't don't take significant every
once in a while I do I have to tell them
for periodic p huh those are the bigger
mark down some some timing stuff I'll
tell you how the time
nothing
it's that kind of possible something I
exactly a loser chicken Oh Walter space
after Donna was worth struggling here
something you think me something we're
hearing those AI something certainly
should be
it was good morning
seven
you know what can give you a seven
listen enough
switch real a close me
be ready those day before though okay
but you're right choice i'm gonna close
quote someplace past about anything else
mark okay we'll try it faster that's the
whole point yeah
right afterwards take all you I'm sorry
why did you pull what was closed book
and I tinged they could be changed right
yeah
looks half of the space
iya iya John dr. beginning just like him
for the horse auctions
me too many you have whatever I don't
know it just sticking around 20 lines
you get rid of the bellies
the one without a we did have a close
quote fourth remember right here I
started there that look at the w will
dock w their 23 fighters one
I'm pretty sure is to open closer its
beginning because it's safe yeah and the
strong a single one is and there's two
closer quotes here since I spend not
necessarily well yeah said castle base
gee yeah oh teri kasam so try afford
being right and then try to close recent
study yes if they're too close both were
comma both spaces yeah let's try that
okay I'll get rid of it ok 829 DW about
that more benefits doing what you can do
you might want to just take a look and
well close it what you got in closing
try and decode of you Thank series try
the word hello decrypt what what I know
oh we know what I don't know what you
are thinking about that's my you go in
there I think our time yeah by mistake
on his head hurt our case so okay so we
had a little extra at the end there that
wasn't that wasn't supposed to be in
there I guess I'm not gonna get the emmy
award for this one okay so well comments
on this what to me that the most
interesting thing was that be that this
solution had fewer had almost no
incorrect letters on the screen for for
more than 30 minutes every 30 seconds or
a minute or so most of the the incorrect
things somehow were ferreted out quickly
perhaps just by cautious approach but i
think there was also because of a some
of the methodology there so that so it
was soup it was even though there were a
lot of blanks not not filled spaces the
ones that were filled were were
amazingly correct
to me
and well and as you saw write it but at
the end was one of the other thought you
know near near getting a lot more words
coming through so again it wouldn't have
taken that much longer to to get the
whole thing what do you think anything
more okay that's all the third one by
the way I the third one is the first of
some that used the that used the non
Pascal output use use use the the curses
package so that's why I put it no you
didn't use curses like these curses and
all device to get device depending
kisser dressing oh you did okay I'm
sorry then my title is is incorrect for
as you'll see we have numbers that email
is always right
bar you said okay okay wasn't going to
since this escapee oh we got characters
her two kids and then I don't overall I
feel caricature hello okay let's escape
it so it looks like good and dolls but
well that's true
look you know maybe I may be a life you
go back like I said it could just be too
could be can utilize go back one oh my
god there looks like this can only
personalized oh it could be just about
yeah we don't we don't really know okay
lovely let's just get together what is
perfect good traditional look out
screaming hmm bleh i'm just going to
know if you like the blanco dollar
so we look at this one and that one
okay i'll give you some
yes
yeah why not
double quote and seven good business
again seven noble beasts um it could be
but bracket had a dollar sign got it
won't be some number dollars was put
together sees a file up there to be
I get very many of these already
oh that looks
and
this looks reasonable looks reasonable
it's got that miles okay let's keep the
boat here that's bad give her that dash
this ain't acceptable enough these texts
we don't know what was it possible yes
it was possible it's the beginning of a
sentence it could be anywhere discussing
how to put the O letter sure o space and
he says it's fake yeah let's do a search
the next message this can be a capital W
ADW I think yeah 69 yeah
Oh what let's get rid of that good we
got a card to turn line through there
see what the leading it to brunos know
it was a quote to reduce k pal singh
examines you're better pants on so then
you can back me on this but no no we
lost the art of the double quote and see
what could happen yeah okay then that
quote and the sort of tied together
right it would be come if it were so it
would be something
monkey bar if it if it were see I can't
get on here semicolon semicolon
semicolon just like escape cheer
so
it's one word that idea contrariwise was
so it might be the more so would be but
it isn't painting that's logic
I know no it's not enough letters there
it's a five letter let's take out all
fabulous lighter side what are the
possibilities for that missing a good
question no how that was the first that
was the first resolution and I guess I
have to apologize for giving a little
hint there i think at the end making
these times a little bit on I mean I was
a as a referee I just couldn't resist
but I should have held back okay now so
you can see there the several several
advantages of the of this kind of
display where you can move the cursor
directly and also type ctrl P to show
what the possibilities are I guess and
control L was what so now let's just
look look at possibilities 00 was
control p as i was about the whole like
an escapee was escape be with an
giddiness always a stability screech
position so so a variety of different
tough
of different heuristics we're done in
there probably not all all dreamed of at
the beginning but after having worked on
the previous cryptograms they saw other
features i think i could put in because
of this interaction that was suggested
actually that escape feed the first
program i wrote that was the only thing
had uh huh right you know it's that was
that to find the ones that would duck it
does show promising things to try next
because they were fairly small number of
size and I like the world it said I
would like to comment in there so these
two things are linked it gives you a
feeling for how Purdy BP somehow the way
you worked on it give you good fit for
the interdependencies between you know
when you lose this you lose the clothes
and things like that I think that was a
helpful helpful thing okay so any other
when did it say what he said the two
things were linked that was when they
were trying to put a okay they had a
carriage return line feed that was
spurious and and there was a there were
two open courts in front of that and it
didn't look great very good to have open
quote carriage return line feed
something like that and so so as they
were removing the open court or the
catch no like a thrust it they thought
the open quote was wrong so they were
moving the open quote and then they lost
something else good i think in the most
too early so that's if I meant the fond
memories correct and then now they
realize it was a carriage return line
feed that was furious because the way
the linkage was going the open quotes
look more reliable than they I mean they
were losing some good stuff by that
all right okay so let's roll the protein
for now so okay so I'll so on your mark
get set
think that I know what I'm associate
possibly
No
the second is I engineer
I teens persistent angle it appeared it
as well over here so late I eg when it
appears with it from oh so I things like
this I think
yeah I think
see how many frozen to jail
every move i guess the only word
innovation from others i can think of as
roma
thank you
teaching try it fun no it's too bad it's
okay oh my god ok I think that's Nicky
it is persuasive whoops i love
food
the spring get away
can you try to you so let's go that with
a leafy he did quiero e dismissing okay
now just you'll see you know that we do
need you should still asleep the EU you
No
I know what you the best avi avi avi on
y.o.u you tapas traffic ' now
so if it were sure okay fine Google bang
oh yes oh ok so did he give us a motel
so this was up yeah so very very close
solution and I I think actually the
foreigners they know their literature a
lot better than Americans because up you
saw the passage where he had key in
there and then tried queen well he also
looked for cabbages now he had a he had
an inkling that Lewis co was it was a
little bit like Lewis Carroll I think
because the cabbages and kings is
another lying from from my house
Wonderland man when he had King in Marin
and this was before this was before
Tweedledum got into the action side said
I thought so so well ok now you notice
that a lot of typing had to be done
knowing in this by comparison with the
width with the previous method and so a
time and motion study of the of the
solution which probably identify a
bottleneck in that part of it other
comments
I it's uh I was a the khleevi
competition situation of course is in is
is involved in all of this too it's not
the same as if you were sitting at your
desk calmly doing your daily cryptogram
because at one at one point it seemed
like everything was hopeless and so you
wouldn't believe it if it were any other
beauty marks are very close to some hang
any company so looks like the very good
international cooperation there and
getting through the things like the at
least I can't I can't say that the that
you appeared to be at a disadvantage
with respect to Americans because and on
the literary things that it seemed that
they were superior okay now the next one
I so I put grip in the title because as
you'll see they also have the program
that use that use a UNIX utility that
searches the entire english dictionary
for for a regular expression for all
words that satisfy certain patterns and
during the next presentation that at
when when grep is called it puts its
outputs on the bottom of the screen so
you'll see words in the bottom of the
screen that were supplied by grip some
some calls that that would that would
that would be take place you know in the
part that do we happy that we aren't
seeing so so you'll see that they that
they yeah every once in while they would
they would search to see what are all
the words of English in the dictionary
that have a certain a certain thing and
at one point for example you'll see the
word sojourn at the bottom
you won't see exactly when they call
that but there was a place when sojourn
was the only word that would have fit of
the conjectured path word order to be
our genes and you there
ok
like that that's sort of the only thing
that's going to be housed on the screen
here we go the other sisters basically
come yeah london right yeah up squirt
practice
applause
so let's try to fail Illinois trust
someone
anyway januzaj let's look some stuff
suspicious about the bracket look like
me private kotik on yahoo trash the car
yeah okay what the can I cabin so
much let's do this thing he can do that
code in the beginning is survived the
Nama here the last time you used clothes
he did eat breakfast till he approaches
there's a sudden here in and out before
searching so it's time on the stews I
mean nobody serves as a show source of
this nation indication of our members
and yeah how about drunk and had a
double backflip see as long as they are
to them
a specialist in fighting Trident go
things no all right but you can't give
you a lot of matches yeah two letter
word with heels into the letter oh there
are the remains that just go see how
many letters to live in front yep too
many problems not many after
looks like it's a two out of punctuation
f grade just found the options be he
that's a beer he gives us any other
information no thankfully guess it is
that for me these things are like a
crossword now the punishment is fed up
and here ! or its single close quote
double quotes you need order today or
can be a semicolon well finally let's
look for some higher level stuff before
a position in any number of literary
what's a paragraph two thing is dialogue
how about looks search for said
she said wow that looks quite good but
limit or does this mean yep definitely
boy yeah take it hmm now till the
sandwich we always been accessing I
don't know i trashed long everyone's
again ami is going to try okay we should
gain or eliminate that official
taran'atar success dash KBS creature ok
let's go down listen closely this was
weird like yeah what could you a grep
words beginning with cosmo than you all
right I don't fit clothes on no no just
yoga yeah I doesn't look like this isn't
okay just going to do smelling monuments
when my coach following this way
promise I like to past tense there now
it's a real more minutes I mean of
course there could be a lot more than
anything there's no other times I on yep
that any why does not look good and it
would you wanna come from I mean I that
time is wrong he's not I came from the
walk I'll be isn't of us maybe we should
leave it in pain he look like this looks
like last words are cleansing countless
this one's a capital
this one if this careful analysis
instrumental ok have a sky firm or
cousin or words and see what would be
good
this because let's go make this
continues I'll keep looking under where
the 99 you how to be there shall be as
fresh die Thank You universe is there at
the same the other suspect continued
okay I'm happen okay i'll continue to
you again for whoever is how could you
ready o space jumpers rather watch by
some one clock okay then partnership
okay doesn't it isn't isn't sir yeah no
no no no no if it was so no I understand
the wrong place isn't
yeah that was that was really impressive
to me to see somebody just going through
and and typing on a thing and they were
going beep if you know if it doesn't fit
and really nice versus VI philosophy
that was that was really yeah I mean I
when I set this problem I've I didn't
conceive of such a beautiful solutions
as as these work that is this high level
of interaction between possibly and so
so I so this idea of just going into
cryptogram and saying well now what do
we leave here we type this in here and
then it'll as beep and so you know it's
Veronica immediately I've seen it in
other programs but I somehow I never
thought of it he's not in a solution to
a 204 problem it's a damn and that
really wasn't it now that I said I would
discuss the highlighting when you when
you look at it a letter and see you put
your cursor and you and it displays what
characters could it be some of the
letters were highlighted now this
weren't and if I remember correctly the
ones that are highlighted are the ones
that fit according to all the other
things that have been deduced so far
yeah ones that aren't highlighted are
also possible if you've made a mistake
of with the other F but they've no
they're up there they're possible in the
original cryptogram but but have been
ruled out unless eat but in order to put
it in you have to you'd have to lose
something else
and so so that was a fairly effective
way to display that to focus your eyes
on the things that are more likely but
you also know the absolute absolute
situation so and I know how seems to be
the hardest time hardest thing in
vacillation well it wasn't really a word
that's probably anymore ok any other
what does a good idea what those are the
vehicle you are mean anyway um no no way
but it was just that in it in knowing
it's at this peculiar I've never seen it
except in this part of alison wonderland
and they just had these two characters
that are identified one of them oysters
contrariwise another one always says no
huh and that's okay and then you know
you see pictures of them and and they
are they have our arms around each other
and one says dumb one says d on it on it
but they there's some debate as to
whether or not they were wearing each
other shirts I mean well that's up it's
just as far as i know a rather rare word
but it does very nice in that passage
yeah okay now for the four-team number
six
and my honey mark get that is all you're
ever get some sleep
okay just because you okay mmm bugs how
about another yeah relevant Pacific in
five
hm Australian Prime hot children arts or
no let's go back in the dark senator
thank you well how does
okay she was search result our spacing
for coming
ooh I could pop character Oh of us about
section haha what the garbage
Oh No
ok
on the sole color
mud yeah the Los Feliz oil people who
else is actually the first baseman space
for me hmm yeah it was so it might be
volunteers the enthalpy holy the motion
show close as possible oh hi
it might be space well see Kimmy space
ha-har condition is get over from either
your color or poison what's up there as
possible please the philosophy called
this move also runs up it would be e and
yes I'm sure he was
Oh feel dumb people turn away I don't
know it's under sex it is tell us how I
thought you know for kids so who does
not love the deep
implicates the ones that we didn't like
all along ok and Israel scrolling you I
know what you did I think you can come I
love wait but listen I nobody out there
that don't post winded up there about so
to come but it wasn't subtle oh just
delete it
Oh
o.o spoonful
no how yeah your system here okay
spinning up sometime oh good night oh
thank you boo ya bastard that's fun
okay let's have a hand I would see there
were several things to one of the things
that I think as far as as far as helping
the team work was concerned it was it
was an interesting thing that when they
just 18 when the possibilities of her
position are listed they stay stay on
the screen for a while so somebody on a
team to be thinking about those while
somebody else was thinking about I so
you got a little parallelism in there
between the team members which was
another instead of being cereal I think
that might have had some some effect on
let's see what's the other no other
comment tu Familia what one of those
numbers the numbers what what numbers do
I know the business or the highlighted
numbers they were how many possible yes
that each thought and the bottom of who
was how many different positions had
same person so yeah it would like would
say for tune whether these are four
possibilities there was something else
that also be affected directly so for
this flat had four possibilities and and
I need something else also had to save
flow equivalent for facilities and so
then you and I see that you know
somebody out there were the other for
two or sitting 6 i'm wearing and that
you use that at the beginning to attract
each of the tuning and seem to see which
one was better my father's look at the
ones of all they had a couple
possibilities and yes so that was a
similar to the escape p that you say was
the first thing in rot Roger he said it
was the first thing in here here I take
to court another way of displaying
kind of information so they can we see
the the thing you're typing going on the
bottom up instead of hana it's just I
guess it's about the same amount of
typing going in by now I'm not sure it
seemed like more keystrokes were needed
to put in the guest is finally but it's
a pretty good winning solution I didn't
I don't think I I gave any clues to that
team but like i did to a couple of the
others foggia nice to have a team of mr.
muffin be introduced just so you can
have a latte because we didn't get to
see them during the issue oh oh oh yes
with the ribbon of wood Karen and rich
and end up there too yeah John come come
over here right well just to tease they
just for you to the team since the
Teamsters oh well we had that one we had
that the first yup are we happy okay
well let's see I guess because they
aren't sitting bye-bye I'm saying
together okay because we we introduce
everybody the first day at class but
well let's let's let's continue the
discussion though first I think okay now
I what about the in general then you
notice that we had three people solve it
in 45 minute three team solve it and
three things didn't and there was a
novice characteristic between the two
namely what screen oriented instead of
instead of instead of just the terminal
output yeah so for interaction this this
looks pretty conclusive that that
that that significant time advantages
come from that and it's not at the
moment it's not des portable to write a
program that way but soon it let's hope
it it would be computer science moves
slowly to the things that are more
understood we used to understand only
only arithmetic expressions and and
pretty soon we got to the point where we
can understand a little more about about
terminal output and even lower case
letters and uppercase letters mixed and
so on and now our dynamics of our output
to dimension loss but positioning things
going in time beginning to get more
understood and more portable but it goes
it takes a while before the ideas
crystallize the point where they are
standardized enough that that you can do
them on lots of different machines okay
other comments now about in general
about this problem what did you think of
the solutions to the the first two
cryptogram stuff the Pascal program for
example just press that I mean and
licentious basketball program was the
simplest anticipation of houston okay
now i got to tell you a little story
about the past that Pascal program i
wanted to write an interesting pascal
program that would still be less than
256 bytes did anybody catch why the
program might be considered interesting
is it rancho could you Ryan is what did
it do Hey well I got more of it yeah I
bring it out itself okay so now no I
know now include including the sale yes
well yeah abseil where I ran it on the
editor has an interesting peculiarity
and that is you have a maximum of 120
three characters per line after which
you have to have a carriage return and
and I believe there exists no
self-reproducing program of two lines
that talk that has 122 characters per
line in I mean with 122 I would have
would have been able to do it with 123 I
just barely made it with 1 923 and other
line 122 followed by the carriage return
line feed everything in a
self-reproducing program is doubled if
you can't make a change of one character
to the program if you save one you you
actually saved 2 and similarly if you
need one more it puts you two over and I
was very close to the limit and if I was
doing it on score where I don't have
that restriction and I could write a
one-line program that would only have to
have one ripened statement in it and
each reitman accounts for w RI t e ln
into parentheses and and double-a than
you you say 40 so it's not the shortest
possible self-reproducing programming
peskow but it but on sale it is and I
think it's unique I think there's no
shorter one for sailing in 40 score it
has to be almost almost that long I
think okay not on the other leg but
there's a sort of a folklore about
self-reproducing
ramset Oh another thing I'd Floyd
sometimes talks about in his court now
let's see I think it out I guess even
before I started solving it the defuser
privileges in program because I got what
is the what is the only kind of
interesting probably connected that's
our space yeah I think you're right
that's also it's unique in that sense ok
so then you started out and saying well
I'm eating right now now actually in
algo w language was the best one of the
best for self-reproducing because you
noticed in the 60s we could that was a
language that that costs of it made up
just before Pascal and and it had much
much richer string syntax and and you
could run you could write a
self-reproducing program on one card 80
columns and you could punch it and it
would punch out the same card in those
days that was that was the interesting
constraint and and for that you could
you could use the substring notation
because you had to double the other you
two quotes to get a quotation mark
inside of a string but you could use a
substring that would end with the first
quote and then the substring that
include that first court again you just
barely fit into beautiful little things
well so Donald the numbers of the chrg
cheat you know what the program is
trying to do yeah that's why I ascii
code it was a little bit machine
defendant in that sense it's the only
way to get quotes out contesting and I
tried introducing a constant Q equals 37
or something like that or q parts maybe
a string constant Q equals cheer 37 and
if you count the number of characters
and that just you still lose but making
money to was used for x rays
we're five times it wasn't enough to
account for the abbreviation that you
buy five that you had to declare a
constant in equal sign was close going
there okay now the other quote was taken
from an article by Jim reeds and Peter
Weinberger in in the this big issue in
the bell a technical journal last fall
about unix system and this there was a
an article about how to break the unique
script command which I quoted from there
and they discussed some other aspects of
it that we didn't have in our problem
for example there's there's a son like
some extensions that have been proposed
to to make the thing more secure and
they gave methods of breaking those
provided you knew the or finding me the
the funk the key provided you knew the
plaintext exactly you knew the hope the
whole message you would still there was
still so for some of these you there was
still some interest in finding me the
way it was encoded because in another
message which would have the same
encoding could be used I should mention
that when encoding first came to
Stanford life now we they installed it
McCarthy installed it out at the AI lab
which was in it well up on the hill at
in those days and I heard the
interesting story I think it's true that
the first thing that John did was I was
in cipher several of his files and then
next week he forgot the key and nobody
has ever been able to figure out since
what what was in those files so they
lost room so they have a pretty good
method on that one
oh ok yeah is there a way to to start
another tapers that are the question
yeah ok ok because I would like to have
another five or ten minutes of
discussion I think as it's for well as
question our mind ok just let it come
notice that them and ok let's let's uh
I'll start again half a minute The
Libertines intake
while they're doing that I just went
like I'm sorry for the jitter on it on
the screen and you know the fact that
some of the letters aren't readable I'm
unreadable now and that's another thing
that work that you'd be able to tell
your grandchildren you remember the days
when they couldn't do this because you
know slowly but surely we're getting our
more connection between digital and
analog equipment but at the moment you
can see exactly what the interface is
like now using that Sony's best anyway
there's people finally coming to grips
with this problem in making better make
better equipment at first the only the
only people with million-dollar budgets
are able to afford the equipment and
then then it it gradually trickles down
so we can't do instant replace the way
ABC Sports to us what let's see that
again yeah all right let's see it slow
motion the stuff aside
I I wonder what it wouldn't happen if we
had just switched the six teams around
in other words self that the first team
had come up with sis with the 22-minute
solution and then had gone the other way
but in fact this is exactly the order in
which they wish it took place i don't
know maybe the wreck of the walls
weren't so secures people listen ok i go
ok what time ok so so I think we might
regards if there's a few more things we
ought to talk about so I'm running the
class a little overtime today but we
will have lunch before long Andy yeah
yeah it's not to mention that well the
English text the site the first one
isn't actually totally unique I mean you
can't get all the characters you're
relieved that all those responsibilities
well honest the last character could be
a period or an exclamation point for
instance all eyes they're both
semantically plausible ah ok so we did
it so yeah ! sairam probably not used in
technical literature but you didn't know
that yeah I had in fact Bob Floyd sent
me a letter once thing that I shouldn't
use so many exclamation points in my
books you said Don don't use you use too
many exclamation points and then he says
exclamation exclamation it's driving me
crazy three explanations we don't all
scream you know and so itself so uh so
after that I have tone down my own
personal use of exclamation points but
then all right well that's a that's
interesting and since you have your
program stuff show the possibilities for
of four-letter you have a pretty good
feel for how many they typically ought
to be getting a message there's lots of
possibilities you can imagine finding a
lots of English words through there and
even at the end as you say this visit
hopefully so this gives it a
some some kind of intuitive feeling
gfive ministers okay we have some kind
of intuitive feeling for the for the
possible leads a number of possible
suspects that that come through the
output now so what about the methods to
improve this this kind of inside frame
what would be number one number two it's
on ways that that might work to make
this thing harder to break later twice
doing country no no not necessarily no I
mean I gave you this thing that f of X f
of f of x equals x and f of X on equal f
of X and things like that but but let's
say suppose we didn't want to change the
method too much we still in and have
something like it what would you think
where you can break the cycles longer
than to link to okay they're yeah
they're robbing seem to be any any
particular reason for for for respecting
F in that way as far as efficiencies
concern you needed to you needed both a
pin it's in verse 14 encoding decoding
but that's not such a big deal intent
you can add characters which are not in
your typical character set I mean that
instead of saying that this only ask
because how would you do that if you
know on the per unit area
depression other than that accident okay
so first you women so first you would
compress the data through some kind of
my hoffman coding scheme or something
that that uses frequency and gives you
more in the bits and then do it inside
free that would that would mean that all
of our art strategies that were based on
on the fact that each letter had only
had about eighty percent of the Tommy
forty percent for the possibilities were
only surviving yeah that was that and it
would make it with shot of Charlotte
messages instead of 256 characters
shorter than 256 256 was okay but 100
would be really really hard yeah okay so
that the fact that f of f of X was equal
X that sort of gave us effective to on
everything also I can't mean a chance
that that we've another part of the
message would would hit ok but adding
multiple to count instead adding one to
the first went to decide how to multiply
that oh you don't know what it is before
the am sorry so change that to some kind
of social something other than a simple
addition for someone for some maybe
something which is a function of a key
canal is something that's another key
what isn't that the same as changing
changing it to F I mean if here we have
we we've got C to the minus something
well okay I think that's right as a
function of position on top of a so more
random function of position on top of
the random function of the of the key
yep potassium applying crypt twice two
different passwords how violent i'm
applying trick twice with two different
passwords anybody want to shoot that
down besides me is that what doesn't
that give you the same doesn't that give
you just yourself any irritations to get
into mouth give us like we're two
different keys she's to me yeah this
gives you this gives you the other than
two cycles but i believe it's probably
true that any permutation you can be
written as a fraud
have two involutions I'm not absolutely
sure that but i think that's that's
well-known probable or false but i think
its limit for yes okay well good ideas
ranjith on them all down and so tuesday
we meet on an end continued problem
three ok now if they want to be the
people on the teams to come up and get
and get on TV I get